Puck comes toward the slot Eric Holla Vacuums
in to scoop it away paa runs into pilot so some
Friendly Fire there and the pucks turn the other
way Keller drops it off here's AER and Matt Dumba
scores in his first game with the coyotes the long
time Minnesota Wild defenseman gives Arizona the
lead he has all kinds of time and space with that
crossy speed as enters the devil Zone and look at
that Patience by Keller draws a few Defenders to
him and then he drops it off the B Dumba who has
all kinds of time starting to pick up their play
there's more urgency moving their feet moving
the puck around getting some opportunities but
you're right the C shutting it down Jack Hughes
in off the feed from tle and Vela was ready
with the glove another great chance there and
M has been good cooly lowers the shoulder kick
save Schmid as he w handed that one toward goal
allows Hughes to come away with it three on
two stays on side across for Breton kick to
De it bounces off Escape look at to Center for
Hughes Dumba breaks it up nice idea Tooley the
right-handed shooter coming down the left there
a lot tougher to handle that puck it's got to
be a perfect pass for a quick redirect now it's
Coy two on one delays gets it a save on zooker
that's a big the coyote defenseman at Hughes
butela shuts the door and then CARiD still how
young he is how little he's played at the NHL
level because he's been so rock solid and was
so good in the playoffs he's called upon here
and gets a piece of BU that shot melli hacking
away and Schmidt says no like an Arizona Coyote
team continue to get better they're young guys
continue to develop it just makes it that much
more difficult Devils did hit a post Jer brat
with a great opportunity Keller feeds Jersy up
top Keller gets it back Keller shoots and he hits
the underside of the bar and it comes out what a
release ukat moves it here's Keller and that hit
the post after Schmid got a piece of it Keller
faked that slap after he' taken it a couple of
times earlier on this power play about a minute
in the offensive zone now for Arizona Keller at
the dot feeds the point dery WS fires and scores
Shan dery with a ho from the Blue Line Arizona
leads two- nothing to give the cies a two nothing
lead but they had spent the whole minute 20 minute
25 about of their power play before they score
in the devil Zone and that wears penal Killers
down eventually an open Lane there they get it
to dery but it was a little bit y schz four on
four ripping this one wide open Ice here for
Jack Hughes and Jess for brat they a two-on
one Hughes carrying forward across for brat his
[Applause] SC give the Devils an inch they'll
take a mile and Brad makes it a one goal game
well the Devils definitely needed that dynamic
duo that connection remember anything can happen
in Jersey 4 on four hockey two onone Hughes to
brat nice little saucer pass right in the wheel
House of jper brat here's Marino who out of the
Penalty Box down the wing Marino wrapping around
he tried to Center it and it was intercepted lost
and crou Johnny on the spot melli back for bu
across to melli and smid makes the pass I don't
think melli got all of it for 9 seconds so this
is important it's a faceof win for Arizona yo
balamaki moves it across Moser down low a Turn
and Burn shot save Schmid denying Nick bu that
Hamilton sends it back to brat along the half wall
Brat's pass skipped off Heir not clean yet for the
Devils but Jack Hughes has some space now and the
devils are set up with 43 seconds left in the 4 on
three hu it's for Hamilton what t
score duy's done it two nights in a row tie
game finally doing just a couple of passes
between brat Hughes and SE douge kind of
circles around and gets ready to te this
Puck up and he rips it past fala good screen in
front by ni oisha the captain durman got in the
way Hughes shoots that bounces off hir Hughes
gets it again 40 seconds left in the five on
three Hamilton down low to Foley to Hughes
extra pass BR he scores again a power play
goal the devil's lead fell behind two nothing
to the coyotes and they take their first lead
and they stayed patient here bill they have a
two-man advantage and they fired a couple of
shots a couple of a block they miss handled a
few passes but they were able to retrieve the
puck because of that two-man Advantage eventually
they really moved the puck around here and look
at that perfectly placed shot Arizona runs
into penalty trouble and you don't want to
do that too often against this Devil's team and
now they got a you got to try to go do it again
heer in the slot it's turned away by Vela as
the devil still have 30 seconds seconds left
on this five on four power play he'll wield
forward 10 seconds left in the period he is
looking for magic at the end of the frame he gets
inside come backhander Anda Ked it out to spoil
would have been an already have multi-power Play
Goals tonight it's game number two of the Year
well we know special teams is always an important
part for any team during the regular season and
certainly to start the season off with how tight
the game's going to be but still a long way to
go go in this one but one goal games how do you
manage and there's going to be so many one goal
games they regardless who you're playing carcone
for O'Brien Schmid makes the first save he is
sprawling out for the rebound it's dug out there
by Brendan Smith with a lot of traffic in front of
Akira Schmid P didn't make it through McLoud
battling didn't get it out as dery holds the
line schmalz from the slot a diving block Jonas
seen ther that's rug off the post and in Nick
scholz from the short side beat Schmid
to tie the game Brink it that tied it or
brought him with in one regardless as far
as a broken play huge block Arizona's able
to hunt that puck down and keep it alive
and Scholtz can really shoot [Music] it
huge block you saw there one more look
at it by se but kulie does a terrif
job very entertaining three on three as we know
and Michael moud starts at the draw as he did so
often last year and he wins the face off back to
Jack Hughes so now McLoud will peel off so good at
that cut back and just that Glide that's able to
here he comes again Hughes has the jump Hughes on
the rapper outa sticks the pad and gets there just
in time great job by Eric holl but probably trying
to do a little too much coming all the way back in
his own Zone with that pucking then it could have
been dangerous one last chance and it's broken up
by Marino going down to a knee we're headed to a
shootout on night two Long Reach likes to go to
the back [Applause] hand mad got Schmid down and
scores this time beforehand but he's got that long
body and it's tough for goers to pick up little
fake shot real nice job by buad so wait Schmid
out as he goes down on the fake shot and Arizona
scores pressure on the devils and jper Brad who
scored twice today BR delays and Vela redit the
entire time how good as Carell Vela been since
Midway through the third period yeah he's really
been on it and I think this a pretty good move by
braaa just doesn't bite he stays with it all the
way and seals the bottom part of the ice left pad
save Nick schmalz sent this game to overtime with
a goal late in the 30d he can win it for Arizona
here schaltz goes slow speeds up and scores
coyotes take the full two points and win their
season opener Devils drop to 10 in one through
the opening two games Devils unable to get that
3-2 or the fourth goal and there's SCH beautiful
set of hands that's just a lot of poise and smarts
he's got a quick release terrific shot third star